Ryann O'Callahan played in the NFL for
six years including a trip to the Super
Bowl with the New England Patriots hello
mr. Kraft back in 2017 I love mr. Kraft
back in 2017 O'Callahan opened up about
his personal struggles 2017 that he
faced on and off the field in our series
note to self
you're going to invest all of your
energy and time into football
so people refrain from asking your least
favorite question where's your
girlfriend you're going to start chewing
tobacco in order to look more straight
don't do it you're going to gain as much
weight as possible so that people see
you is unattractive you're going to do
everything in your power to make sure no
one finds out that you're gay you know
that if your cover is blown you'll lose
everything if you're gay you're as good
as dead
think about that for a second O'Callahan
is now out with a new book my life on
the line how the NFL damn near killed me
and ended up saving my life Ryan
O'Callahan is here with us in the
greenroom it's so good to see you
whenever I talk about the note to self I
always say that yours is my favorite
because it is so pointed to me and so
relatable for so many people and when
you talk about in the book my life on
the line how the NFL damn near killed my
killed me killed me and then I'm saving
my life I go back to that bite where it
said because being gays as good as dead
because that is what you felt Ryan you
felt that there was nobody you could
talk to you said football was a good
beard for you because inside you're a
little gay boy with a big secret yeah I
was absolutely convinced growing up
hearing the things I heard from family
and family members yeah and you know as
a child the things you hear out of your
family's mouth they stick with you you
know and I don't think a lot of parents
out there realize that your kids are
listening in a few years you use
derogatory language like that you don't
know how to damage your kids and it
affected me you know pretty pretty
heavily and it stuck with me throughout
my life but the thing that struck me
about your book is that you knew at a
fairly early age didn't you that you
were gay or that you were different what
did you know and what age were you yeah
you know
I think all your little boys five six
seven years old you start getting
crushes on girls or boys but as soon as
you hit puberty and the crush turned
into more of like a desire you know that
you're gay and for a little bit I
thought okay maybe this is a phase
quickly I found out it wasn't you talk
about watching Saved by the Bell where
the people are looking at the girls
you're looking at Zach how stereotypical
I know I know we all have our type but I
the thing that got me is when you said
it's exhausting being with anybody in a
relationship but for you you said you
had to be on all of the time what did
that mean being on all of the time
pretending yeah when I was closeted I
was always just worried what other
people were thinking and I always tried
to control a conversation because I
never wanted someone to ask you know who
you're dating or different things like
that and I would I would always look for
opportunities just to be by myself get
away so I wouldn't have to worry or
think about what others are thinking I
was consumed with that football had to
be kind of a relief to you because can
there be any more masculine sport in the
world in football in terms of when it
comes to hiding you said that was a
really good place to hide yeah I mean it
may sound silly or somebody locker room
is a great place to hide because you're
just one of you know hundreds of guys
there's one of the guys and especially
moving to a new city you can tell them
whatever you want there's no reason not
to believe you so in football being so
masculine you know my parents fans don't
really assume for the most part that
someone playing could be gay and I
assure you there's a lot of gay football
players out there hmm you can insure us
that yeah well it would make sense I
mean you know if you look at the
statistics in this country it would make
sense that that is the case yeah that
you know you like you said just the
facts the numbers and and you know we're
I hear from quite a few of them and
we're trying to change things and make
it easier for them to come out and work
with the NFL to make it easier as well
hopefully we make some progress with
that I want to go back to RINO Callahan
in high school because this is the thing
that got me about you because I when I
met you a couple years ago I thought you
know he's such a good guy he's such a
gentleman
and really considerate new said in high
school I was basically your jerk except
you use the a word yeah and that you
would go out of your way you said to you
regret to this day your behavior what
did you do yeah I was your stereotypical
bully big men on campus you know I think
most bullies are a little insecure about
something so they just project and take
it out on other isn't but you would say
derogatory things about gays yeah well
you know that happens a lot and and I
would I'd pick on people I was I was
pretty brutal and I just I'd rather
known for being a jerk than you know
something else somebody who was gay yeah
and he said I regret that I've given
some apologies and but even when you
were doing that you knew that you were
gay you knew that oh yeah oh yeah and
that was just me lashing out at people I
was insecure and you're thinking I don't
want anybody to find out oh yeah
so then you're struggling with you start
abusing prescription drugs you start
having suicidal thoughts because you're
thinking the only way to really free
myself is to take your own life
that's how dark it got for you yeah I
didn't think my family would ever love
me as a as a openly gay man I thought
you know like I said in the book they'd
love him more as a dead straight man I
know how ridiculous that is ridiculous I
was closeted I was just consumed in my
head and wasn't thinking straight no you
said they would prefer a dead straight
man than a gay man who was full of life
yeah done that just sound crazy to you
now when you sit there and think about
this yeah after I came out I quickly
learned well for one how much my family
accept me and love me no matter what and
but just there's a whole community out
there even if your family doesn't
there's a whole community of people out
there that will you know open their arms
and love you and and you know kind of
give you a place to go in a lot of ways
and yeah that's what I try to do now is
let people know that and just feel
accepted and welcomed you had played for
the Patriots and you played for the
Kansas City Chiefs and you're in the
locker room and you do get the question
where's your girlfriend yeah what's your
answer
what was your answer yes my go-to answer
was she's back home it wasn't it wasn't
unusual for guys to live
the city also in New England air in the
season back home in the offseason so a
lot of guys did that so it wasn't
unusual there you know there was one
case in New England where we went to a
mr. Kraft had a big party so that was
like bring a date yes oh yeah that's not
bringing your friend Brian yeah so
really was your best friend yeah he was
my best friend but yeah that was one of
those things where I had to bring a girl
so I had this friend who was an
ex-girlfriend of a college buddy and
like she'll come and and I was very
clear just just friends and it worked no
I felt like that bought me some time in
the locker yeah or anybody to start
raising questions about what's going on
with him yeah but but how do you survive
in a football culture or in society when
you can't be yourself when you're
hearing all the jokes and you're hearing
the ridicule and you're hearing the
disdain what what is going on in your
head how you're processing that and how
you're feeling yeah I mean I I back then
I just took it all to heart I remembered
everything they said and it just made me
more and more depressed you know now you
hear things I just I don't let other
people's feelings affect me I've learned
that that's really not that important
you know your happiness yourself is the
most important thing and I just focus on
the positives and then what I can do and
not what others you're angry about for
whatever reason in May 2017 you decided
I'm going to come out publicly but you
had told your parents you tell us the
reaction that your parents had when you
told them yeah so my old were you then
when you told your parents so I told my
parents in 2012 I was just turning 30
and I'd started pushing my family out of
my life and spoke to him in a few months
because I plan on ending things and I
thought that would make it easier on
them so when I did call my mom and say
hey I'm coming to town and she thought
you know I was gonna be terminally ill
or something because I was backing off
so when I told my mom she was quite
honestly relieved my dad you know I
thought it was gonna be like an
Armageddon situation ya know things
flying but he was pretty quiet told me
loved me but it took me about a year to
even acknowledge that I told him you
know and then meeting the first guy I
dated that kind of really hammered it
home for him but since then everything's
been
fantastic we're closer than we've ever
been that's good and your advice you
have advice for parents to who who may
be struggling or what the message that
they should send to their children yeah
I you know for me I think the only thing
that would have changed my outlook on
things when I was a kid is if my parents
at an early age is sat down and said if
you're gay just let us know it's like
it's alright it's okay just be yourself
be happy will love you no matter what
and I think anything short of hearing
that when I was younger you know
wouldn't have helped much so I just
encourage parents watch what they say
have that conversation with their kids
parents need to understand it's not a
choice I mean it's not a choice
you can believe what you want you know I
respect all that but it's really not a
choice and you're not gonna change your
child to just love them and let them
know they're loved not only that you
said not only you have to tell them but
you have to tell them repeatedly yeah
because most people grow up not hearing
it in your book you say most people grow
up not hearing anything positive about
being gay so you said it's not just good
enough to say it once you have to say it
repeatedly yeah just you know kids like
to know that they're loved and accepted
so just let them know remind them you
know one off is good but just keep
telling them and and slowly they'll you
know believe you and and and gotta come
into their own and and it's different
for everybody but what is your message
for people who are listening to you who
are struggling trying to decide what to
do because not everybody feels
comfortable and coming out and sharing
that part of their lives yeah everyone's
situation is very different you know I
hear from people all the time and I just
encourage people to try to look at the
positives you know I I never until the
very end thought maybe I could come out
to just take a second look at the
positives and realize it's never as bad
as you think it's gonna be and start by
telling one person that you're close to
and the feeling after doing that's
amazing yeah that'll kind of build in
the next one but if someone isn't okay
with it that's fine yeah the end of the
world you know it's interesting what you
said no you had planned on eight not
telling anybody never getting married
and not acting on being gay you were
just gonna be what after football I was
just gonna be dead on ending things no
you write in the book you had a great
not great but you had a very graphic
visualization of how you intended to
take your life how you were going to
tell your parents
the note you were going to leave I'm so
glad you did not do that yeah but help
us understand this before we go and I
know we have to go how the NFL damn near
killed me and ended up saving my life
what does that sentence mean yeah so
that has a lot to do with you know the
injuries and everything I went through
in the NFL which led to an addiction to
painkillers but it was the professionals
on the team that noticed me going
downhill that took me aside taught me to
help I need it now they didn't know why
I was abusing the painkillers
conciliated myself but they recognized
the problem sent me to get help and I
didn't have saved my life
we're glad you saved up do we dare ask
about your personal life or you and are
you happy I am are you in a relationship
do I need to find you somebody while I'm
looking for myself
yeah good taste I am single I am happy
okay good I'm looking all right me too
good I am happy I'm single
Ryan O'Callahan we thank you Ryan's book
is called my life on the line it's now
available wherever you liked him maybe
you and me right now that would be a
story where he likes to buy your books